the Democrats looking to challenge
President Trump in 2020 are calling for
the full release of the report but some
are already pointing out that the
election will be more about different
issues than the now completed
investigation of correspondent Peter
Doocy takes a look at the candidates
strategies going forward baito
isn't ready to let go the Democrat
Democratic challengers to put this
behind them as a lot of Republicans have
been suggesting or do you know but other
Democrats are warning that it'll be
tough to win next year if candidates
keep clinging to collusion in 2018 the
election was about Republicans not
kicking people off of their health
insurance for pre-existing condition
2020 is going to be very focused on
economic issues so guess what we can do
two things at once
ensure the law is followed and make sure
we're focusing on an optimistic economic
agenda the surging South Bend Indiana
mayor Pete Budaj
seems to agree that Democrats stand a
better chance running on policies not
probes I think this is further evidence
that it would be a mistake for Democrats
to think that the way for the Trump
presidency to end is by way of
investigation that could of course
happen but we've got to be paying
attention to the kinds of conditions
that made it possible for somebody like
him to get here in the first place
candidates still haven't seen Muller's
report but they're dissatisfied with the
abridged version from the Attorney
General Stacey Abrams still considering
a 2020 bid said quote I tend to think
it's kind of like having your brother
summarize your report card to your
parents cory booker believes that quote
the American public deserves the full
report and findings from the Moller
investigation immediately not just the
in-house summary from a trump
administration official and elizabeth
warren tweeted Congress voted 422 zero
to release the full mullet report not a
summary from his hand-picked attorney
general AG bar make the full report
public immediately the swells gathered
to see Bernie Sanders in California this
weekend erupted in cheers at the mere
mention of an unredacted Mulla report
I don't want a summary of the report I
want the whole damn report the
front-runner is behind the rest of the
pack though because we still don't know
what potential candidate Jill Biden
makes of Muller's findings but that
could change tomorrow Biden has an event
in New York ironically at a restaurant
called
the Russian Tea Room Brett Peter thank
you